non-minimalists
what's the best way to balance hustle
and rest while growing
a business should you hustle hard from
the start so you can
relax in the future dude when i was
reading this question i thought it was
funny
so when you're an entrepreneur like i
don't think you ever relax
no i don't even know what that word
means anymore oh my god academic terms
well you know what's funny man is like i
was talking to mariah about this the
other day i'm like
because i've been having such a hard
time sleeping late like i got the aura
ring like trying to like you know trying
to
track my sleep and get better sleep and
i realized like there's always this
constant
pressure on me for you know us owning
our own business now it's a pressure
that that i really enjoy having
yeah but as an entrepreneur i don't
think you could ever truly just like
uh sit back and relax i'm always jealous
of the nine to fivers i know that sounds
weird but i'm like
wow so you're just went home on friday
didn't look at your email at all
you just left like yeah you just left
your work that's amazing over there oh
wow yeah yeah i totally agree
but here's the thing when we were in the
corporate world we were we weren't nine
to fivers although people think that we
were like five to niners
yeah yeah beyond nine really it was uh
so the very first thing i did in the
morning was check my blackberry when i
woke up
at 4 44 every morning hipster um
and uh well i would wake up i'd write
for an hour
uh and then i would start my day and uh
first thing i do though is check the
blackberry and make sure there's no
emergencies
and the last thing i did before my head
hit the pillow was check the blackberry
and i was checking it every minute it
seemed like of every day
and and you know what what do i have to
show for that well i have some i
developed some skills along the way
but also i was developing products and
services for someone else that
i wasn't necessarily benefiting directly
from
right i wasn't building up these assets
i was building up some skills for sure
and so i had to think about it in a way
where
i was hustling for someone else yeah and
i
in a weird way was being hustled yeah
well that's for sure true
yeah so so if i have a pithy answer for
this it is this
don't confuse hustle with productivity
creativity
or quality amen and if a sec if i could
have a second pithy answer podcast sean
for the show notes here
it's say yes until you have to say no
then say no until you have to say yes oh
that's so good
you guys are so good at this so so let's
talk about both of those things real
quick jordan
so i mean the first thing is well
we often confuse hustle the thing we
talked about earlier i'm i'm
gtd getting things done but are you
really getting
are you getting the important things
right most people aren't and i'm just as
guilty of this as anyone else
my to-do list dude all right here's the
sign if you have a to-do list
and you put something on it that you've
already done just so you can slide it
and cross it off you got a problem
right you're doing the busy work and i i
still sometimes
catch myself doing this i'm like oh i
did this thing i better wait midway
typing i'm like delete
it doesn't need to go in there you know
you're gamifying the system you're using
todoist or something like that
you've got to be really careful with
that if you
try to take these big bites what is that
book called it's like eat that frog have
you heard of this
no oh i can't remember who wrote this
it's called eat that frog
and it's about doing the important
things in the beginning of the day
instead of like
well first i need to make sure i have no
emergencies in my inbox and then i need
to make sure that i go and buy
tunips turnips whatever at the store and
then i need to
feed my cat and then i'm gonna make
these calls and then
busy work right it's busy work and you
throw things in the way and this is a
subconscious process where you go
i really need to do the book cover
because the designer's waiting for this
thing that i got to do and it's
bottlenecking this whole project you go
but i have all these other things to do
because you don't know what you're doing
and i when i teach networking and
relationship development
to either special forces or corporate
people or whatever they're always like
oh it's a low priority they don't say
that but they
indicate it and the reason is because
it's a black box it's like i don't
really know how to do this but i do know
how to tweet and i know how to answer
instagram comments and i do know how to
craft an email for my list that doesn't
need to go out and i know
how to tweak crap on my website you push
things to the bottom that are important
because they're harder
and so it takes more cognitive ability
to do it
so you push it to the end of the day and
you go oh well i don't have time but
look at all these other things i did
today
and you're depleted you're completely in
the day so you can't even focus on on
the important thing and then the saying
yes i mean at first especially when
you're first starting a business and
that's why i
phrased it this way say yes until you
have to say no like
you can accept all these new
opportunities it's brand new eventually
though you're going to get to a point
i think ryan and i have done four
interviews all year this year and we've
said no to hundreds of them yeah sean
has said no to hundreds of them
and and the reason that we have said
no is because we want to focus on what
we're creating right now there will be
another time where it makes sense for us
to go out like we did in
2014 and we have to say yes 400 makes
sense for us to say yes we don't have
anything but yeah yeah exactly when does
it make sense and so
for like tammy when she had her question
earlier tammy from st pete
yeah she might have the opportunity
right now to say yes to a bunch of
clients at a lower price
to build up her clientele build up her
referrals but eventually
she's going to get so many clients her
price is going to go up and she's going
to have to start saying
no no no no no until it makes sense for
her to say yes to the right
opportunities yeah
absolutely and you know the the
dangerous thing is that the the the
social media the
uh facebook the emails the phone calls
going and buying turnips like
this can this can feel like a hustle and
you know what actually it may it might
even
you could consider it a hustle so here's
worthless hustle right so here here's
here's my pit the answer uh for nick
here
an entrepreneur needn't focus on
hustling as much as adding value
yeah like that's people always ask like
oh man i want to do this one
you know so i got to side hustle and i
want to really break out and you know
you guys are entrepreneurs like
what's your biggest piece of advice and
like our biggest piece of advice is
is add value like if you are adding
value to people's lives
just like we do with 99 of our free
content people are willing to support
you with that one percent of stuff that
you charge for people are gonna find
ways to go out of their way and support
you yes indeed
all right our next question is from bob
how does one
overcome the fear of insecurity of
moving from the safety net
of guaranteed income to the mentality
that they can succeed and survive
on one's own well i think we kind of
alluded to this
my short answer is job security is a
misnomer when your security is in
someone else's hands amen
and i think quite often like so you're
on wall street you're like well this is
this is
job security i've got the job that i
want now but then
what happens the stock market crashes
and all of a sudden
that security you thought you had that's
the rug has been pulled out from under
you and now you're falling because
you didn't create that security it was a
sense of false security
and the real security comes when you're
willing to to
well when you're willing to step back
and realize i'm going to create my own
security first
sure i agree with this 100 i think there
is
the the illusion of job security in
in someone else's employ and the problem
that we have is
entrepreneurs or business owners were
like yeah i'm just gonna jump and then
hope
what happens hope it works out that's
also a bad idea it seems heroic now
again instagram influencers and
youtubers are like bro go all in quit
your job and start a blog that's right
but what i what i would advise because i
get this question all the time on
the and you guys are so good at naming
things i had to name my show the jordan
harbinger show which just sounds so sad
now
it's just my name the minimalists.com
was available for seven dollars at the
time
so that's that's why we're the minimum
fantastic
what i always advise is hey look keep
the job that you have
until and i said this earlier in the
show until you're the bottleneck yeah
and you're not the bottleneck because
someone else has to do your social media
you're the bottleneck
when you are the only thing stopping
yourself from scaling you have to be
brutally honest not just like well i
really hate my job this last month so
maybe i'm the bottleneck now no it has
to be you're coming home from your job
and from 7pm to whenever you fall asleep
at the keyboard
you're doing something only you can do
that's when you make the leap yeah
and you've got income coming in and it's
pretty stable from your side hustle or
whatever it is your entrepreneurial
venture
don't quit before that and that makes
this choice so much easier
because people what that what he's
asking is when do i blindly quit
something that's paying the bills
and then just pray to the powers that be
that my new thing
starts making money you don't the answer
is you don't do that yeah don't do that
absolutely so
you know i guess going from the art of
charm to what you're doing now right
um like you like you would mention at
the beginning of the podcast like
there's you're making good money
you know there's there's this stable
source of
income um is there any practical
and i got some practical stuff too but
i'm just curious jordan is there any
practical stuff that that you did
to ensure like you know what i can walk
away from this paycheck
and i can start something else uh and
and feel
you know you're always gonna have a
little bit of fear but to alleviate as
much fear as possible i guess
what i did at first and this was kind of
an accidental discovery what i did at
first
it was like step one panic step two and
but limit your panic to like a couple of
days depending on how traumatizing it is
uh my friend hal elrod who you guys
might know he's like you you can feel
sorry for yourself for 15 minutes and
this is a guy who
had cancer i think twice and almost died
in a car accident so i'm
he can speak credibly on this particular
point okay i'm gonna have to look this
guy up yeah he's amazing i'll introduce
you guys
and uh he wrote this book called the
miracle morning it's it's pretty
interesting
what i did was step one panic step two
make a list of people
that i know will help me and this list
could be a hundred people but what i did
is i started with like 10 or 12
who i knew would not say no and the
reason i did that is because
when you're feeling low down out
defeated whatever it is
you don't want to call people where
you're like hey can you help me and
they're like oh
um i'm really busy because you'll start
to feel even
worse because you'll see your support
network slowly slipping away yeah
call 10 people that day or the next day
and you go look i'm having a really big
problem can you can you
help me that first dozen people that you
call that help you
you start to feel bulletproof you're
like well if i've got 12 really good
friends behind
me i'll be fine and this can be your
parents but it's even better if it's not
right because then you're like oh okay
it's not just my family who's like you
can do it honey
like thanks mom you can do it and you're
handsome yeah it is
and your mama's handsome boy that'll
only go so far but if you call your
friends and they're like yeah i'm
happy to figure out how to help you
that's when you start to go wait a
minute i have a huge support network
and so what i encourage people to do i
call this exercise layoff lifelines
because it's like imagine you get laid
off
who are the 10 or so people you wish
you'd kept in touch with like your
college guidance counselor what a great
friend right like because if you make
that list now
and it's like oh you know i should have
kept in touch with josh and ryan and i
should have kept in touch with
my high school guidance counselor and i
should have kept in touch with that old
boss and i should have kept in touch
with these professors that were really
good
make that list now reach out now because
then you don't have an agenda
because the problem is people go oh it's
so awkward to reach out it's awkward to
reach out when you're like
hey man i haven't talked to you in eight
years so i need a job right so i need
help now my house is on fire can you
come put it out for me
right that's awkward we're working on
our second documentary right now and on
the soundtrack that we're working uh
with uh drew and nate on um from this
band
we um there's a song called
asking on there and the line is
it's just man it hit me like you can't
listen to it yet so
there's nothing i can give for you to
listen to impossible
but uh the line is uh i'm sorry i didn't
call
i've just been busy yeah and like but
when you hear it in a song especially
that's the thing it's
it's not like you're setting these
people up as i'm gonna need to use you
someday
you're setting up to say hey man i
screwed up i didn't keep in touch with
this relationship
let me find a way to repair this this is
something that meant something to me it
doesn't mean
they're going to be your best friend
forever now it just means that you're
you're repairing or you're reconnecting
with this person
so you can have a meaningful
relationship with them if they need
something you need to be willing to
help them out this is what a
relationship is there's an us box in
every relationship i'm i'm
giving what i can give and i'm taking
what i need not everything i can take
but taking what i need from the
relationship yeah jordan i i i think uh
i just want to highlight how like when
you're going and asking for help
it's not even like you're looking for
handouts man it's like when
when you're asking for help you're
looking for support but i think the
other thing too is like you all
you are also offering support and i
think that is how
uh you can really make these
relationships strong and you do have
people to kind of fall back on i mean
it's
you know maybe uh maybe bob here doesn't
have you know someone who can offer him
a job
but you know maybe maybe bob has some
folks who could you know tell their
friends and family about you know what
he's doing or whatever but but yeah it's
it's it's so important to hold on to
those good relationships my my pet the
answer would be this
uh it's kind of re kind of rewrote josh
doesn't even realize i did that
it is uh betting on an employer rather
than yourself
guarantees disappointment yeah and even
though you're being employed i really
love what jordan's saying
here it's very practical it's not like
well just uh quit your job and
do what you're following your passion
put yourself out there
best dating advice ever so get yourself
out there so that's what i've been doing
right now
i've been putting myself out there i
haven't put myself in here
and so like i i think what's true is
yeah okay maybe you don't have job
security but if you're betting yourself
even in the job you're you're gonna have
better job security in that job you
control the mechanisms that are you're
able to to control
there yeah every promotion that i got in
the corporate world and i got quite a
few i was
by age 27 i was the youngest director in
our company's 140-year history
which sounds really impressive until you
you
realize that like well i was the the
sort of middle manager of who gives a
crap
you know you made the director position
the week before you're right you're the
director now yeah and the younger
congrats
happened to be the oldest one too uh no
and and what i what i realized
in in that scenario is i never applied
for any of the promotions i got i
worked hard at adding as much value as i
could so that i was the clear person
to to pick for the next thing and you
can do that now you can pick yourself
even if you're working within a
corporate structure you're working for a
small business or you're working for
yourself it's important to pick yourself
yeah
it absolutely is i mean you know bob you
might get fired tomorrow
uh your employer does not look out for
you they look out for the company
and to sit there and say oh well i've
got this guaranteed source of income you
do not have a guarantee source of income
you have something consistent that
you've gotten maybe over the past months
years whatever
but there's nothing guaranteed in life
especially your job
um i i think practical you know some
practical advice
save up six months worth of bills like
for me that is what really gave me
uh the courage to when i got laid off
well
the way i got laid off is it was a month
a month before i got laid off
um i asked to speak to my boss and i'm
like hey man
uh you know about the minimalists and
you know that i'm probably not going to
be at this company for the rest of my
life
i want to talk to you about what we're
going to do who we're going to replace
me with if i happen to leave
and he was like oh that's a good
question he's like
man he's like you've got things running
pretty well he's like this thing is it's
going pretty well he's like i don't
i don't even know if i would need to
replace you and i'm like
bad sign yeah well for me it was it was
i just looked at him like huh
that's an interesting thought isn't it
and then the next month i get a phone
call hey man i need you to meet me uh
you know in room 207 across from hr
where like we've laid off dozens of
people before
like i knew what was coming but having
that conversation with him and i knew i
was planting the seed in his head
and having that conversation with them i
don't think i would have had that if i
hadn't
saved up six months worth of bills it's
not like you know i was uh
looking at this safety net like oh man i
can do anything i want
because i got six months worth of bills
but what it did do is it gave me
confidence to
give myself some time a little bit of a
buffer uh
a buffer to to go out there and find
another source of
income so i mean just practically bob
save up six months worth of bills that
will alleviate
a lot of fear oh yeah good point and
it's hard to do that because people go
oh
six months of bills no problem then you
start looking at what you're getting
you're buying and you're like wait a
minute i
probably don't even need to do that yeah
you need to look at the budget and say
i'm
actually probably spending way too much
right now if i just spent less
and i focus on what is truly essential
what is non-essential and what's junk in
my life
i compare pare down my current bills and
by the way that six months that number
is going to be a lot smaller right and
i'm not trying to make this
sound simple i mean it might take
someone six years to save up six months
worth of bills
but but that goal of having that
uh throughout your work career like that
is
i mean for me like i just can't even
express how much
leverage that gave me um when i when i
wanted to talk to my boss about that